desai aujourd'hui déserts du bissière
musique
une manifestation et fellation
notre objectif est de faire à partir de
la musique qui doit retrouver versailles
se réintroduire dans versailles un peu
ce que les allemands ont fait entre
bayrou et wagner où les autrichiens de
salzbourg et mozart et nous pouvons
trouver le même lien entre versailles et
la musique baroque pas simplement le lit
mais également au rameau couperin pas
cette musique a été une des premières
musiques d'europe à ce moment là un sou
des trois siècles pour saluer en musique
la création au sens
national de musique baroque résulté par
jean claude malgoire chef d'orchestre
dans l'habitation
diffusion pédagogie et recherche des
muscats sous les 3 missions du
répertoire baroque est très mal connue
aujourd'hui en france seulement 5% de
zaba
il ya encore une bonne vingtaine
d'opérateurs guide rameau et d'autres
compositeurs moins prestigieux mais tout
aussi honnête sur le plan de la de la
qualité musicale qu'on ne trompera comme
marin marais de la lande et serra et
c'est toute cette musique qui reste à
découvrir de façon à ce que cette
musique sonne soit soit entendu et ce a
jugé apprécié à sa juste valeur
aujourd'hui japanese le musicien celui
de la cour de louis xiv a redonné sa
majesté au palais d eau
même le soleil était au rendez vous
à